And then when the Marxist say,
well,
that wasn't real Marxism,
what it really means,
and I've thought about this for a long
time,
it's the most arrogant possible
statement anyone could ever make.
It means if I would have been in
Stalin's position,
I would have ushered in the damn utopia
instead that instead of the genocidal
massacres,
because I understand the doctrine of
Marxism and everything about me is good.
It's like,
well,
think again sunshine.
You don't understand it,
you don't understand it and you're not
that good.
And if the power was in your hands,
assuming you had the competence,
which you don't,
you wouldn't have done any better.
And even if you had,
there would have been someone else
waiting right behind you to shoot you
the first time you actually tried to do
anything good.
And that's what happened to all the old
guard who ran the damn revolution.
Stalin rounded them all up and shot them
along with their families and millions
of other people.
So even if you do happen to be that
Avatar of moral purity that you claim
implicitly,
the probability that you get to act out
your goodness in relationship to those
possessed by Your radiology is zero.